das wollte ich einfach mal sagen und ich
poste jetzt gleichauf insel war ein foto
ohne filter oder alles und ich würde
mich freuen wenn ihr einfach mal drauf
geht und ein gefällt mir das eigentlich
kann ich von meinem bett machen bevor
ich anfange so fertig hey was geht ab
und herzlich willkommen bayern ein video
ich hoffe das mikrofon im moment ja war
an alles cool
leute ich hab natürlich geht es gut mir
auch dankeschön der nachfrage ja ihr
habt mir wahrscheinlich schon gelesen
was machen wir heute erst mal gar nichts
wenn wir hier sehen könnt 29,7 prozent
von euch haben gerade mal den channel
abonniere die das video schauen deswegen
jetzt schon abonnieren würde mich sehr
freuen
dann kriegen wir das schon bestellen sie
jetzt wahrscheinlich am wg schon gelesen
es geht heute um ungeschminktes
geschminkt bevor sich jetzt einige von
euch denken was das denn viel
oberflächliches thema der macht er sich
ja bestimmt und darüber lustig wie
manche ungeschminkt aussehen und zwar
ist mir in letzter zeit einiges
aufgefallen vor allem wir waren auch
instagram unterwegs ist das problem ist
halt das wird halt irgendwie immer
stärker und ich frage mich um ehrlich zu
sein wo das hinführen soll instagram ist
eine coole app keine frage und ich nutze
sie auch gerne aber ich glaube ich habe
sie früher noch gerne mehr gerne noch
lieber benutzt als heute weil man muss
ganz ehrlich sagen das meiste davon
entspricht überhaupt nicht mehr der
realität an sich ging es ja mal darum
leuten einfach zu zeigen was man so
macht er halt einfach fotos miteinander
zu teilen und dabei war es jetzt nicht
so wichtig ob man genau den passenden
moment erwischt hat oder genau den
passenden filter oder wenn ich mir
heutzutage einige sachen angucke ich
find's cool coole fotos zur post auch
als fotograf fotos gut zu bearbeiten
aber ich finde die realität geht dadurch
komplett verloren
die meisten influenza posten einfach
fotos die komplett verändert wurden und
postern in die story tab to edit und ein
foto das am anfang eigentlich ganz ok
aus sah es plötzlich bunt mit
irgendwelchen farben mit irgendwelchen
lens flare irgendwelche lichter und den
leuten gefällt also ich weiss nicht
bearbeitet meine fotos auch gerne so ein
bisschen ins blaue aber so komplett dass
sie gar nicht mehr aussehen wie vorher
es gibt ja jetzt schon apps da kann man
sich so ein sixpack draufziehen da kann
man ihre hüfte dünner machen da kann man
den a sprecher machen man kann ja alles
machen und das problem ist diese app sie
gehen durch die decke theorie dass jetzt
wieder so viel
aber so was kann man doch nicht als gut
bezeichnen instagram ist für mich
eigentlich eine komplette feld jetzt
hier das youtube-video gut dass
schneidig aber es ist ja an sich ruhig
geht das video von mir ist 100 maria als
irgend so ein dummer instagram post von
irgendeiner blöden influence drin muss
sich einfach mal loswerden und deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht
ihr könnt mir gerne mal ein foto von
euch ungeschminkt und einmal geschminkt
zukommen lassen haben wirklich sehr
viele von euch gemacht wir schauen wir
uns mal zusammen haben könnt ihr
natürlich auch weiterhin machen ich
würde mich sehr freuen wenn wir auf
install verfolgt alex wie ist ein genie
und ich habe mir überlegt bald mal
einfach wieder mit fotos einzufangen
ohne groß filter drauf zu laden oder
sonstwas deswegen folgte auf jeden fall
und ihr könnt mir auch gerne weiter
fotos von euch zukommen lassen für den
nächsten party wenn teuer wenn darauf
bog ab leistete nach oben da machen wir
bei alex song tik milliarden oder so wir
voran mit dem ersten foto schilling
grüße nach hause nehme mir ich weiß also
nicht nur die namen von euch das hier
ist das erste foto ungeschminkt und an
sich ist das wird ja wirklich hübsch man
könntest du auf instagram posten und ich
würde sagen cooles foto beispiel mal
rüber zum geschminkten und hier muss ich
sogar noch sagen finde ich auch gut wenn
mich jetzt fragen würde rechtsschütze
besser könnte ich gar nicht sagen weil
hier ist es noch so da wird halt so ein
bisschen make-up draufgemacht fertig was
ich übrigens auch super finden folgende
fälle und zwar krieg ich so viele fotos
ich sage schon immer bitte ohne filter
und dann schickt sie mir einmal so ein
bild
und dann dieses bild von da kann man
halt gar nicht sagen welches ist denn
jetzt mit make up welches natürlich
nicht schlimm nichts gegen dich versteht
das nicht falsch würde aber mit solchen
fotos kann ich halt absolut gar nichts
anfangen das gleiche gilt dann auch für
solche fotos einmal hier ungeschminkt wo
man auch sagen muss cooles bild pause
ist auf install alex macht gefällt mir
und dann kommt das nächste untersteht
geschminkt und ich denke mir so nah
danke für dieses bild ein großer
unterschied ist zu erkennen so einmal
ungeschminkt nochmal foto kommen wir
zunächst ein sondern wir haben ja einmal
das ungeschminkte bild wobei ich mir
jetzt da die frage stelle
die augenbrauen ist wenn die wirklich so
ist und daneben haben wir einmal das
geschminkte union
was ist das denn danke für die bilder
hierzu kann ich sagen ich finde es ja
voll in ordnung wenn man zum beispiel
dass in der pubertät ist unseren pickel
hat und so
geschminkt damals wo ich immer noch
pickel habe wenn man da ein bisschen
make-up darüber mache aber das heißt ja
nicht dass es viel schöner ist als und
wenn man sich dann selber wohler fühlt
ist ja kein problem kann jeder machen
wie er will das problem ist nur dass die
gesellschaft irgendwie komplett zu denkt
man muss den anderen leuten möglichst
gut gefallen und das verstärkt das ja
total dass man sich immer mehr schmecken
wenn man mal filter aus bild klatscht
und die hüfte dollar machten den arsch
dicker und so weiter haben auch sehr
viele jüngere geschrieben was ich will
ich gut finde ich kann dir leider kein
bild schicken geschminkt weil meine
eltern mir das verbieten also eigentlich
gar nicht mal so schlecht
wobei ich das eigentlich auch falsch
finde man sollte es halt nur nicht
übertreiben kommen wir zunächst ich
glaube die sache noch etwas immer hier
haben wir einmal ungeschminkt und hier
haben wir geschminkt und das wird zum
beispiel ein fall da muss ich ganz klar
sagen finde ich jetzt gar nicht besser
geschminkt ist natürlich jetzt auch nur
minimale unterschied aber ich finde da
könnte man das war ganz weglassen dann
hab ich auch noch dieses bild bekommen
hier haben wir einmal ungeschminkt und
daneben einmal geschminkt mit dem
kommentar heisst scheiße du bist zum
anbeißen er ist halt auch wieder so wie
eben wenn man sich dann selber wohler
fühlt warum nicht nur ich glaube würdest
du jetzt aber das erste bild in
schwarz-weiß verlegen wird es gut
vielleicht bis auf die augenbrauen
genauso aussehen wie das geschminkte
glaube ich was ihr euch auch auf keinen
fall vorenthalten will und zwar haben
wir hier einmal ein foto von mir wie ich
normal aussehen und einmal wie ich
aussehe wenn ich einen videodreh hat mir
eine zuschauerin geschickt danke dafür
ich finde das kommt eigentlich gut hin
oder machen wir weiter mit diesem bild
man muss auf jeden fall sagen coole pose
auch cooles bett und hier muss man sagen
im vergleich zu den geschminkten bild
was jetzt kommt das finde ich schon
krasser unterschied ich meine auf diesem
bild siehst du so aus wie 16 vielleicht
sogar 17 und auf dem bild sowie 13 das
heißt was ja eigentlich immer eintritt
wenn man sich schminkt dass man älter
aussieht ja sehe ich also wenn du jetzt
im club gehen willst schminktisch
ansonsten brauchst du nicht so zwei
machen wir noch einmal hier
das ist so schöne grüße an dieser stelle
wir haben wahrlich einmal geschminkt
glaub ich ne genau kommt hinunter leider
hier wieder normal aussieht muss ich
sagen da gefällt mir das normale
eindeutig besser muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen so wie du geschminkt aussiehst
körperlichen die tonne treten
dass ich das jetzt so hart anhört aber
ich muss auch wirklich mal meine
sorgen in diesem video ich habe auch
wirklich mega viele bilder bekommen das
sieht man einfach überhaupt keinen
unterschied zum beispiel schaut euch mal
dieses bild an das ist glaube ich
ungeschminkt und nicht andersrum ich
habe keinen plan an sich sieht das hier
eins zu eins gleich aus ich habe keine
ahnung ob du irgendwas verwechselt hast
oder ob ich mich ja leute ich würde
erstmal hierbei belassen ihr könnt mir
gerne weitere bilder von euch zu
schicken wenn ihr sagt alex macht doch
bitte noch ein paar dazu gibt nach oben
ab juni nicht vergessen und sogar sich
alex w
und vergesst mich instagram ist nicht
unbedingt dazu da sich komplett zu
verändern für ein bild das wollte ich
einfach mal sagen und ich brauche jetzt
gleichauf installiert ein foto ohne
filter oder alles und ich würde mich
freuen wenn ihr einfach mal drauf geht
und ein gefällt mir da last ja wir sehen
uns immer mal wieder gibt es ein mega
cooles video ist habe ich schon fertig
gedreht aber leider nicht geschnitten
also haut rein